how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
relating to Marvel and the MCU and today
we have some really exciting reports
going around talking about the possible
return of Robert Downey jr. as Iron Man
/ Tony Stark literally if you type in
Robert Downey jr. returning as Iron Man
there are a ton of recent reports and
Robert Downey jr. has recently hinted
that the door could be still open for
him to make an appearance and apparently
according to these new reports Robert
Downey jr. is willing to come back under
two conditions so we'll talk about what
those conditions are and the possibility
that Robert Downey jr. could be
returning in this video if you're new be
sure to subscribe and notifications
turned on to stay up to date on all
things relating to the MCU and so you
can enter my giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox one or a ps4 now again there
are just a ton of reports out there
right now about this subject a lot of
people have asked me about it so here's
what's going on according to multiple
media outlets Robert Downey jr. is
considering the possibility of returning
due to the failure of doolittle dolittle
greatly underperformed and apparently
due to this Robert Downey jr. could come
back and the first condition of his
return of course is money that's the
first condition and if you throw enough
money at him of course he would consider
coming back the second condition and
this is actually pretty awesome the
second condition is if he gets to work
with Tom Holland clearly Robert Downey
jr. and Tom Holland grew very close
together working with each other in
Captain America Civil War infinity war
and of course Avengers in game and of
course spider-man homecoming and they
even worked together on Doolittle so
apparently those are Robert Downey jr.
stew conditions money and working with
Tom Holland
now again recently Robert Downey jr. has
hinted that there could be a return of
Iron Man
while interviewed on The Today Show they
asked him if the door is still open and
at the end of his sentence he said we'll
see in another interview he was asked
people want to see Iron Man come back
could it happen and he said yeah
anything could happen
so even though he has said before that
Iron Man is dead
anything could happen but let's just
make that clear for a second Iron Man is
dead Tony Stark is dead they're not
going to undo that some of these reports
state that he could come back for a
Kamio in a film about what happened
before civil war and what happened after
civil war and that could actually be
referring to black widow right now we're
unsure of whether or not Robert Downey
jr. Tony Stark is going to be in the
Black Widow film but early leaks for the
Black Widow film have suggested that
Tony Stark is going to be in the film
briefly after Natasha goes against Tony
and the sokovia accords he will reach
out to her to try and help her in the
Black Widow film that's not confirmed
yet but that is a possibility but I
think the biggest possibility of him
returning is probably in a spider-man
film and it's most likely going to be as
some form of AI Tony was the master of
AI he created Jarvis and artificial
intelligence that could actually think
perhaps somehow during his lifetime he
created an artificial intelligence of
himself and that could help Peter in one
of the spider-man films and if we think
about spider-man 3 Peter is going to be
on the run the whole entire time and
Kevin Feige has said that he's not
really going to have anybody but he does
have the glasses that Tony left to him
and perhaps there's some AI in there of
Tony or perhaps there's another recorded
message that Tony left for Peter and
this is most likely how he would make a
return because he has stated before
Ironman is dead and we wouldn't want to
undo that that takes away from his
sacrifice and Avengers in game and we
don't want that but him cameo in one
last time for Peter Parker because
remember that's one of his conditions
working with Tom Holland but one last
time with Peter it would make everybody
go crazy so those are what just a ton of
reports are saying right now that Robert
Downey jr. could return and of course
like you said anything is possible if he
did return let me know how you would
like to see him return in the comments
down below also don't forget to like
this video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU and so you can enter my giveaway for
a chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 and
I'm picking a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof